my next guess is a Republican
congressman from Texas and author of the
new book fortitude American resilience
in the era of outrage please welcome Dan
Crenshaw congressman thank you for doing
this I must tell you I first became
aware of you as I think many Americans
did when Pete Davidson of Saturday Night
Live made that joke about you and I have
to tell you I am such a fan of what you
said because you never hear that in
American life you said look it was wrong
but let's just forgive each other I know
you've done much better things for this
country five tours you did overseas but
thank you for your service in calling
out victim culture I appreciate that
bill and first of all thanks for having
me I know we had planned to do this in
the studio in Los Angeles unfortunately
life took a different turn you know the
phrase I used after Pete Davidson said
that which I think you would love this
phrase is try hard not to be offended or
try hard not to offend but try even
harder not to offend or be offense he's
under writing this up try hard not to
try even harder not to be offended and I
thought it would be great a way to live
for all of us no and we both share this
disdain for victim culture and for lots
of stuff trophy syndrome I hope I have
some credibility with you because you
know I did a show called politically
incorrect which started in 1993 what I
think you were about ten and I was onto
this [ __ ]
a long time ago and it hasn't gotten any
better I think you do have some
credibility for sure in conservative
circles I don't know how often you you
test or do focus groups with amongst
conservatives but we generally think of
you as a real liberal and you know and
that means something and there's a
difference between liberalism and
leftism and we can disagree
wholeheartedly on right the best way to
govern our country there the best way to
perceive a problem and the framework
with which to approach problem-solving
but open-mindedness and and the ability
to debate should be a key tenant of
liberalism
and at least in the classical sense and
so now we do appreciate it
okay so let's debate a little bit I mean
you yeah yeah you say in your book I'm
gonna quote your you call out automatic
assignment of blame outward that's what
we were just talking about help me
understand how someone who calls out the
outward assignment of blame can be such
a supporter of a president who does
nothing but passed the buck lie finger
point shirk responsibility tell tell me
how you can support someone with your
background someone like that yeah it
didn't take long for Trump to come up
you know I would say I support the
country right and the president's
success is certainly tied of the success
of the country I support his policy
agenda when I disagree with this policy
agenda I openly disagree with it this
isn't you know Republicans always get
asked this question and there's this
demand that we always have to answer
what do you feel about him well you
don't don't you don't you want to
comment on his latest tweet and his
latest out in his in his the way he
lashed out and and no I don't I can't
defend everything I can't he doesn't
have the same style as I do I don't
consider him my spiritual guide by any
means but but you know let me tell you a
quick story what I was blown up sitting
in my hospital bed President Obama was
doing the rounds at Walter Reed just
like President Trump does now and just
like President Bush did before him it's
a really neat thing it's a really
interesting connection that the
president gets with these wounded
wounded active-duty soldiers that is
never publicized and even though I may
have disagreed with so many levels
with with President Obama I made sure to
get up and I was excited I was genuinely
happy and to shake that man's hand and
have him sign the American flag on my
wall and you know even though we
disagree on political things and and I
think I would like us to get to that
point with this president as well okay
but you you do it a lot of Republicans
do you you you talk about his tweets and
his style I'm not talking about that I'm
talking about the person who's the
leader of the country at a time of
crisis and we have to we have to go
through what he actually has done this
is important stuff it's about life and
death and it's about our economy and
everything that's really important it's
not tweets and it's not style let's just
go through the timeline okay because he
was warned this did not have to happen
Alex a czar his his Health and Human
Services guy
January 18th he warned him about this
and again on January 30th Trump said he
was being an alarmist Peter Navarro
somebody else who talks to Trump a lot
told him directly January 29th you got
to get ahead of this February later two
days later he implemented a restrictive
try a travel ban from China which he was
widely criticized for I have that same
day on January 31st Nancy Pelosi
proposed the no ban Act which would be
congressional limitation on the
president Trump's actually able to do
with that true what that travel
restriction okay but that's right and he
lies about that he first of all he
didn't lie about it what do you mean he
said he stopped people coming in from
China he did not he said he was ahead of
it 43 countries did it before we did
there are still people coming in from
China he only stopped foreign national
okay let me address that because I know
that's that's the people are saying
right now but the reality is that was
about 40,000 people came in after that
these were US citizens and green card
holders and passport holders being
repatriated US citizens so you have to
make the argument then that that we
shouldn't allow them in and it sounds to
me like you're fully agreeing with
President Trump on this when everybody
else disagreed with them and if you're
saying that you wish that that that
travel restriction had been more extreme
okay fine well I you apparently had the
foresight back then but when nobody else
did but the fact is you know we if Joe
Biden was in charge at that moment he's
already said he wouldn't have done it he
criticized it as at the time Nancy
Pelosi actually proposed legislation to
stop it but people people are still
coming in from from China it wasn't just
foreign nationals but let's get off that
let me just go back to the time line for
a minute
February 10th after these warnings he
says it's going to go away in April with
the heat because he had a hunch February
he goes to India this is four days after
the white house coronavirus taskforce
said we're going to have to lock down
the country and dr. Nancy Mason yay
who's in charge of the Center for
immunization and respiratory diseases
wait a second let me just finish she
announced this on the 26th he on the
25th that we're gonna have to lock down
the country he said the next day 15
people have it and it's soon going to be
close to zero March 6th he said anyone
who wants a test can get it which is
still completely addictive February
clearly wrong go forward because I
mentioned February 25th the day before
February 24th that's when the
administration requested two and a half
billion dollars from Congress to fulfill
you know CDC NIH an fda funding to
combat the virus and the potential
spread of it what happened right then
I'll tell you because I was in Congress
but I know what happened did we vote on
a supplemental funding bill no did we
wait days to vote no still didn't vote
on it you know what we voted on later
that we Nancy Pelosi the only thing she
would put on the floor to vote on was a
bill to ban flavored tobacco that's
that's what actually happened it wasn't
it was only a week later that we
actually voted on supplemental funding
that the administration requested your
criticism appears to be based in one
thing that Trump was overly optimistic
that's his style you know again I you
can criticize it that's fine but it
doesn't but it's not connected to the
actions that were actually taken because
if I back up even further
you know February 14th CDC announces
ongoing work with five laboratories to
perform community-based influenza
surveillance and study the spread of the
virus we're trying we're in a
fact-finding mode in February people
forget this we were calling February
this last month the words really not
there's just that's an easy and cheap
accusation because there's no big bold
moves taken like there was in January or
were like there was in March but the
reality is our government was working to
create that test they do they work as
fast as we would have liked and of
course none there's a lot of reasons for
that which I am happy to go into by
March 3rd there was only 102 cases in
the United States and yet I'm hearing
criticism that we should have been
locked down weeks earlier but would you
think the American people would have
accepted that with only a hundred cases
in the
it's States Italy didn't lock down until
March 10th Spang not until March 14th UK
not until later in March because like
Sweden's never locked down and so I just
I provide all of that context as we try
to basically accuse this man of well
he's being accused of having blood on
his hands and and context is so
important here well it is and also it's
not just about being optimistic it's
about being right the world was aware of
this and since when does America take
its lead from Italy in Spain because
those were those were the outbreaks were
half I understand I'm pointing it out
again again for context but if we're
gonna criticize somebody's actions we
have to do it in the context of the
facts they knew at the time and so I
just I'm just trying to be fair here
that I don't really care about defending
him or his actions I just care about
letting people know the truth and when
people make these accusations I have to
ask them a question is the goal to make
Trump look better is the goal to get to
the truth because there's two different
sets of answers for that okay but
sometimes they converge sometimes the
truth is that somebody who says I have a
confirm they converge I have a hunch
this is going to go away is that someone
you would want to observe with I mean my
god I don't understand again why someone
with your resume you were in Fallujah
for God's sakes would you want someone a
commander to say that to you to blame
everybody else if something goes wrong
and then to say you know I have a hunch
the enemy's not going to be in there
what's the time no I understand that so
here's how I would I would describe my
answer to that when bullets are flying
past my head I don't need to raise my
voice and I watered about this in my
book to calm breeds calm panic breeds
panic you know being an optimistic
positive you know exuding positivity and
calmness and crisis is exactly how we
asked our seals to leave and no I'm not
sure I see a lot of evidence for blaming
others may be blaming China although
there's a lot of evidence for that so
maybe that's a good place to play blame
but I did it last round Leeming you know
Democrats here know he's he's exposing
hypocrisy and it maybe and maybe we're
confusing that with blame but no I mean
again calm breeds calm and that's how we
would lead in the SEAL Teams okay
so in Texas there was a six-hour line to
vote a couple of weeks ago it does look
like the Republican Party doesn't want
people to vote especially mail and vote
and there's going to be people now who
are afraid to go to the polls because of
this disease where do you stand on that
do you think Republicans are trying to
stop people from voting do you really
want it wouldn't you rather lose an
election than live in a country where
we're not really getting our franchise
so the lines in in Houston here then
those big six-hour Waits he saw
Republicans are in charge of those
elections the the Democrats are in
charge of our County elections here they
run that the County Clerk is a Democrat
recently one that's that's why they're
in charge
they've taken full responsibility for
those lines because basically what
happened is a lot of machines went down
and that's what caused the lines that
there isn't so first of all it's not
Republicans it's Democrats in these
urban areas that actually run the the
election system and second that there
was no ill intent even I don't think ill
intent from Democrats either there was
mistakes made in Texas you have two
weeks to early vote from 7:00 a.m. to
7:00 p.m. for two weeks straight you can
go anywhere in the county and passed
your vote you don't have to vote on
Election Day if you're elderly or sick
and disabled you can vote in by mail no
it's not the case that we don't want
people to vote that and of course that's
always the accusation but it's not
really based in evidence
you know mail-in ballots do have that
you know there's there's a break of
custody of a vote there there's if it's
not fraudulent there's at least the
possibility for mistakes to be made and
we see that often you know I read an
op-ed recently from a former Texas
member who was going door-to-door based
on voter registration just knocking on
doors and would find you know a group of
non-us citizens but they're registered
there or or a empty lot but it's
registered so if you start mailing all
of these types of places ballots well
then you know it's not ill intent but
there's the possibility for a lot of bad
things to happen and so the question we
have to ask ourselves do we really want
to especially from a national level try
to revamp our entire election system and
with the potential for all these
problems and and for what
exactly and so I don't know if your
question is related to Kovac my team
well there's elections in general well
everything's related to that these days
and there of course there's a lot to be
said about your answer which is a
terrific answer from a press spokesman
for that cause but I don't have time to
do it now I hope you can come to our
show as we planned sometime and we will
take up this issue of whether
Republicans really are protecting your
franchise or not but I appreciate you
doing this I appreciate everything
you've done for this country and I hope
I see in person soon thank you
hey thanks Bill great to be with you
you